is now shankar and ty frank working hard
to develop a new expanse series as we
speak
my sources say yes
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so since expanse left our screens
a little over a year ago now people have
been crying out for another series but
it doesn't really make sense for a new
series because there is a big gap
between where we just finished in the
books in particular and where the next
book carried on a 30-year gap in fact
so i have argued and told you repeatedly
actually that um amazon have considered
a few options for this
the first thing that they genuinely
seriously considered was to make three
movies to cover the last three
books but they very quickly
scrapped the idea they very quickly
realized that actually there was just
too much material and the fans would
hate it they just wouldn't be able to
get anything like what they wanted on
the screen for one there's the time
demand and for two the budget
so
that's got scrapped
they considered just carrying on and
making the next series but there's loads
of technical issues on why that wasn't
really a good idea either
so the alternative
was to have a spin-off series now that's
kind of been
in the glue for a little while it's not
really moved and not had a lot of
traction
but now it seems to be starting to move
forwards
according to my sources and i do talk to
a few people that work in and around mgm
and
now amazon um if you aren't a regular
site tracker these aren't hype
executives i'm not getting leaked you
know privileged information
but i do speak to people that have quite
menial jobs within mgm and amazon and
some creative types and some that work
in and around sort of like the legal
side of things and stuff like that but
they do get to hear rumors about what's
going on at amazon and they are fans of
projects like the expanses when they
hear something they let me know
so what they're hearing is that ty frank
who was sort of um
supervising producer for the expanse
and now shankar who acted as the
showrunner are working together at the
moment to develop this spin-off series
now by the way if you do like the
content please don't forget to like and
subscribe and hit the bell notification
you can also consider becoming a member
hit the join button that little bit of
contribution every month really helps us
to create more content
now there's loads of story ideas
that and they could go along with and
apparently this actual plan was already
sort of
sketched through during the final series
if you watch back through the final
series apparently there are lots of
things in the last series that were a
little bit strange and really didn't fit
in with the series that are going to
make a lot more sense as soon as this
new series is developed and we start
hearing things about it
if this is true then i still think we're
probably six months to a year away from
getting anything like pre-production but
the really interesting thing here is
that it seems to be that these guys are
sitting down and actually starting to
scrap some ideas down on paper so let's
see what happens but guys i'd love to
hear what you think about this rumor
that these guys are actually sitting
down and actually developing something
right now is the expansive series that
you desperately want to return is the
idea of doing some sort of like spin-off
series something that would bridge the
gap between the last book and the next
is that something that makes sense to
you
so please get in the comments and tell
me exactly what you think also if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification
also you can
hit the join button and become a fully
fledged side tracker it really helps us
out
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you